okay we're back on the Internet gavin
newsom do you feel the proposition
system that California has is
detrimental to running a working
government great question unequivocally
absolutely yes the problem is people
don't want to get rid of it so it's
exactly the problem I mean we created
prop 13 we have prop 8 we
constitutionally amended the rights of a
minority based on the whims at the
moment of a mind of a majority but for
whatever reason every time we do polling
asking that same majority whether or not
they want to give that right back they
say no way Sacramento is broken these
guys don't know what the hell they're
doing enough we need that power to trump
you know you know I think the biz behind
that deep behind that is they don't
teach in school anymore history or
civics people have no idea what
government really is they have no idea
what the founders wanted the last thing
the founders wanted was leaving
government in the hands of the people
direct democracy they actually didn't
even like the word democracy they kept
right if they kept insisting that they
had created a republic they did and that
and the whole point of a republic was
that you had many indirect ways in which
the public participated but not directly
yeah yeah I mean of course the public is
always gonna vote for things they like
pay for it no we don't like that part of
it yeah so we want good stuff and pay
not we're gonna know this November in
California with a major tax initiative
and if that does not pass it's very
likely you're gonna see dismantling of
the public education system that already
arguably has been dismantle fornia the
only state in the country that needs a
two-thirds majority both to raise taxes
just change that prop 25 last year
thatis a simple majority to get a budget
passed but it requires still two-thirds
to get any any revenue enhancements so
as a consequence we're going back to the
ballot asking the voters whether or not
they want it is of all I mean people say
this about the presidency in almost all
political Jeff why would anyone want
that job this job of Governor of
California I really that's the one job
in this I do not understand why any
would want because it is impossible to
succeed yeah I don't know about I mean
you know you look at the balance sheet
of the state who
would not want to be representing the
ninth largest economy in the world the
most diverse democracy in of any state
in this country I mean this ha the
highest quality education higher
education in the United States more
Nobel laureates more scientists more
engineers in California than any other
state in the nation it's a pretty
remarkable place but not as we are okay
one guy the ninth largest economy in the
world if it were sown country it would
be in default like Greece that's right
working through it hurry do you believe
that the riots in Syria riots civil war
really it should continue to be an
internal matter for the country or
should others intervene oh yeah we never
got this area well we are intervening in
the sense we are we've put Syria under
very very strong sanctions who are
trying to put more we're clearly helping
them with intelligence with
communications the Turks are beginning
to help them militarily if the question
if the only if we face a binary choice
that we've got to get involved
militarily I would say no because the
only intervention that would make sense
in Syria would be a pretty large scale
american-led intervention because Syria
is a it's not like Libya it's not a
country you know Libya's three times the
size of Syria maybe five times the size
so the rebels can hide in lots of places
this is a small country the Army is
tightly in control the only way we could
dislodge them would be a very very
significant military intervention I
don't think it's a good idea I don't
think the odds of success are great I
think it would end up being a pretty as
we have learned I think over the last
ten years these things tend to be easy
to get into and can get very complicated
but I think there are a lot of things we
can do look this regime is running out
of cash the they are almost entirely
isolated at some point the the military
perhaps we'll look at Assad and say you
know what maybe we can find you a nice
villa in the South of France oh yeah
well I did the thing that Obama did in
Libya
to me looks better all the time I know
the Republicans hate it they don't know
why but he did it so they're gonna they
but but Libya really no they don't know
what's going on but they know he's wrong
see in Libya if you had a large country
the rebels were able to take 1/3 of the
country they were able to take a city
you notice the rebels have not been able
to take a single town in Syria so it's
it's it would be a much more difficult
proposition militarily but I mean in
general it seemed like that approach
yeah absolutely very you know light
footprint limited let the others lead
led the European side it's precisely
what the US and NATO did in Libya is the
reason why Russia is so antagonized
because they supported that and they
said they didn't support that all-out
attack and Russia is key to solving the
situations I read your comment you said
you know we can't it's either Iran or
Russia those are the two countries that
can talk to the Syrians and we're not
going to use the Iranians I mean somehow
the Republican Party still thinks Russia
is the Soviet Union I've heard Mitt
Romney makes actually say that yeah yeah
it's it's you know what's weird about it
is it sort of that's what Putin wants
you to believe they're actually a kind
of second-tier power I'm not
particularly strong but they want to be
this world superpower rival of the
United States and there's only one
person in the world who seems to believe
that it's Mitt Romney so no Russian boom
I mean I was in Russia last week no
Russian police what what countries do
Republicans like anymore it seems like
you know Europe well that synonymous
with social yeah so SCANA de Russia is
still the enemy China well you know we
do with those [ __ ] you know
other than like Singapore in Israel I
can't think of a country in the world
that's now acceptable to the right wing
which is a very strange place that I
don't remember ever America being easy
but problem with all these countries
you're describing is they're full of
foreigners
I hate to tell them yeah hate to tell
them that shows America it's just full
of her that's what they don't like it
all right
do you think there will be legalization
of pot before there are equal marriage
rights in this country no I don't I
think well gay marriage is already ahead
you know on that score well I wonder I
mean I I think state-by-state you're
gonna see a lot of balanus I imagine if
it went back in front of the California
voters that was objected last time I
think it would pass
I think we're going that close I mean
you're seeing laws so many laws to
de-facto decriminalize by making an
infraction not even as to misdemeanor
for critical personal consumption you're
seeing more and more laws like that
there's more heart out of pragmatism on
this coming all across the country you
know the Mexican elections are taking
place on Sunday what's been fascinating
to see about Latin American leaders is
across the board conservative to
progressive on the issue of the war on
drugs they say it's failed it's killing
our people tens and thousands of them
and the US has to change their politics
now let's let's not for they have borne
the brunt of it I mean that's not we get
high they die on my may record Sarah
Palin on marriage equality there is a
there is a chance that the Supreme Court
will decide this and then next year
there will be marriage equality for all
Americans it's a possibility and now
that Justice Roberts is a hippie yeah
now yeah right yeah we don't just have
to count on Kenan that's counting on you
Robert Kennedy Oh Kennedy he's people
say he's independent he's senile that's
I really think he's cuckoo he's gone
over the edge
no okay why is it that whenever the
other side doesn't get what they want in
the United States they threaten to move
to Canada now it's what an empty threat
that is right from liberals and
conservatives ever met anyone who
actually left the country one thing
about America you know we may not like a
lot of things about it because we are
spoiled but it's addictive yeah it's in
my blood you know what I'm not going
anywhere ever and you heard it after the
Supreme Court decision it's like this is
terrible I'm moving to Canada I'm like
for what universal health care like
honestly here's something
Limbaugh say if they if the Supreme
Court upholds the Affordable Care Act
he's going to Costa Rica yeah Rico
country without an army
how about Somalia very limited
government but thank you everybody have
a great summer Real Time with Bill Maher
[Music]
ask Bill and his guests to have
questions right after the show at
hbo.com